foreign
so I will talk about our recent work on
the polynomial calculus lower Bound for
coloring problem
these are the authors
I think one of the picture is
non-typical it's at the request of the
author
so the key coloring problem
it's even a simple graph G and a number
K it asks whether we can call it assign
one of the key colors to each vertex so
that there is no monochromatic Edge
this is a well-studied uh and complete
problem as long as K is greater than two
and we believe it's exponentially hard
and we want to collect evidence for that
in terms of unconditional evidence
um
usually improved complexity this is in
the form of lower balance of proving
increasingly powerful families of
algorithms
which are formalized in certain proof
systems
if a proof system formalized such an
algorithm approach then of course lower
bounds for that proof system which
provides you unconditional lower bounds
for any algorithms that is implementable
in that approach
uh there have been at least two lines of
such work
mcdyerman gave a method for determining
k-colorability which captures many
algorithms and B metal showed that they
can be simulated in resolution
another line is the algebraic reasoning
system
uh like or the stronger polynomial
calculus polynomial calculus with
resolution which will be our topic today
and especially interesting and
challenging setting is when the graph is
randomly drawn
either a random deregular graph or just
random drug
Erdos running random graph where each
appears with probability D over
independently
here we know that with high probability
these graphs aren't
they require at least D overlock demand
colors but in general we don't know how
to give a short certificate for that
so the central question is this
for the resolution system we know uh
optimal lower bounds were refusing that
a random graph is three colorable
or for polynomial calculus or even the
weaker responding thoughts we need less
more much much much less sorry
the first exponential lower bound was
obtained for a class of specially
constructed graphs
and we also know lower bounds in terms
of graph curse which means
the length of the smallest cycle in your
graph
here kaiji Chi means the true chromatic
number which is the smallest number you
really need to color that graph
putting all interesting cases the graph
growth is and most login
and a lower amount for random graphs has
been open for almost two decades and
this problem is particularly pressing
due to two reasons
first as in as the authors in the
L'Oreal nostrum paper mentioned they
view their harness result more about the
pigeonhole principle than about the
graph coloring where the pigeonhole
principle is a structure that they use
to build into their special graphs
in contrast we think average case lower
bounds usually tell us more about what
about most graphs themselves that make
the coloring problem hard instead of
some external hardness you plant into
the special graphs
and secondly as the authors in this
famous paper mentioned quite
counter-intuitively coloring seemed to
be easy for practical purposes
and in fact they struggle to find graphs
that don't have
constant degree with Down Massage proof
in our work provides an optimal answer
to this question
we proved linear degree lower Bound for
even three coloring problem on both
random grass models
and by the well-known science degree
relation you immediately got exponential
size lower balance even when the system
have twin variables
our technique in a nutshell
is to extend the techniques for the
large growth graphs to the setting of
random graphs
now let me introduce the problem
encoding in the proof system
degree d
and before it was known
what was known before this for PC
or worst case I've worked with harness
but not on average oh it works
so let's product
we always expect a fear and discuss a
polynomial array over it
and the coloring problem is in a
blockchain we can express the statement
that there is a k click sorry there is a
k color in of G by the following
polynomials the variables are Boolean
for each vertex V and color I you have
the xbi indicating that vertex V is
colored by I into by color I
xcm say that they're Boolean variables
that each vertex gets precisely one
color
and that no address chromatic
monochromatic
and there is at least one more encoding
that is commonly used called the Fourier
encoding where each vertex for each
vertex V there is variable x v but it's
no longer Boolean but takes value among
one of the uh among the case roots of
unity so naturally in this setting you
require a few characteristics to be not
visible but uh you require a few
character characteristics to not divided
but I'm going into more details for now
we just remark that it is now that in
terms of degree the encoding don't
matter
now let me introduce the polynomial
calculus proof system PC insurance
it operates on the in the polynomial
ring
so at the start we're giving a set of
polynomials P1 through PM with it called
the axioms with the intended meaning
that they have a common zero
and PC wants to refill that
it arrives new polynomials from the old
ones step by step according to these
rules linear combination or
multiplication by variable
so a proof line is always a polynomial
written as a sum of distinct terms
and the the refutation is such a
derivation process that gives you one in
the end which clearly tells you that
there is no common zero for the ATC
I've been on such a repetition we can
measure it by degree
that is the largest degree of any
monomial appearing in your proof or by
size which is the number of monomials
counted overall lines
traditionally most math and CS papers
care about degree measure
but improved complexity we care about
both
fortunately
we have a degree size relation at least
in the setting of Boolean variables
which says a linear degree lower bound
can imply exponential exercise lower
audience familiar with resolution this
is analogous to the benches and vectors
in relation
from now on so we will concentrate on
degree
to prove a degree D lower bound say
capital D prefixed formally just like in
many algebra proof systems we only need
to design a dual object in this case
just linear map
so that it Maps adding an axiom to zero
and stabilize if you stepwise and Maps
up imagine proof to zero but it doesn't
map one to zero
as long as these are satisfied then
clearly there is no degree D proof
such a map is usually called a pseudo
reduction but that's just a matter of
name and the whole point is how to
actually construct a such amount
to make the construction we need some
algebraic setups
the most important thing is a true
reduction operator
here the standards starts is that we fix
a total ordering of the monomials in
polynomial array which is like Pokemon
bases calculus
such that it respects multiplication and
in our application it also respects
degree you can think of that as
comparing two monomials by degree first
then lexicographically
and a polynomial by default will be
written as a sum of decreasing monomials
with coefficients
the first one is called as leading
monomial
under the setting given any a set of
polynomials you can say
we say that a monomial m is reducible by
this set W if it is a leading monomial
something in w
otherwise we say it's irreducible
very interestingly when w is a linear
space of polynomials we have more you
can show that the whole Space
actually is a direct sum of w and the
linear span of the irreducible monomials
here the symbol means that
two subspaces do not intersect and they
spend the whole Space not one two plus
this immediately gives you a linear
operator which is from the whole Space
projecting to the second Vector there
called the reduction by w
and of course this kernel is w
just to give you a quick example
if the whole set of monomials just X and
Y
where X is greater than y
and say w is the span of
polynomial X Plus Y which is this line
and the projection operator or reduction
Operator by w
check is a contraction to the y-axis
on the direction of w
that's a reduction operator
you can also think of it as given any
monomial it tries to find an element in
W to make the best cancellation so that
the result is as small as possible
so naturally it doesn't decrease
monomials
either doesn't change it or return it or
return your polynomial with strictly
smaller leading monomial
of course be about easily generalized to
any linear space within order basis but
we don't need that in our application W
is in fact more special it's an ideal
which means it's linear space and
absorbs multiplication
now we can start to say how to prove
degree lower balance
given a set of axioms
the problem is clearly about how you
capture everything that degree DPC can
derive from the axioms
so far we only know that they form a
linear space due to the linear multiple
linear combination rule of PC
the starting point is a very general
local Global principle
for each individual axioms
we always know what expresses
semantically and perhaps perhaps even
you take any 10
and the conjunction of any 10 of them
you still have a good sense of what it
says
but if you take the conjunction of all
and suddenly as a whole
we lose track of what it implies
doesn't imply contradiction
yes precisely what makes MP problem
co-mp problem is hard
and proof system should encounter a
similar situation like us at least we
believe so
so assume for the moment that we have a
notion of blend a subset of axioms is
small you can imagine it as set size
we call such a small set of local sets
and let us always assume that a local
set is satisfiable locally satisfiable
each local set generates an ideal as
denoted as is and have the corresponding
reduction operator RS
now if we feed PC with such a local set
of axioms what can I derive in degree d
well imagine the case when this ass is
really really small in the stronger
sense that it only mentions D many
variables then degree DPC is simply
deductive complete it can derive any
true conclusion about these variables
inspired but at least in turn in the
case of Boolean herbals of course
not inspired by this the way we think
about small degree PC is that they're
locally super powerful
which means we think that any polynomial
in such an IIs as long as itself is
degree bounded by D as easily derivable
probably the local conclusion
then to cover everything PC can derive
in degree D of course with better sort
of all such polynomials in that is take
their linear span
um you can think of as we take the local
conclusion from all possible local sets
imagine such a con collection
consists of all the small all the Axiom
subsets of size for example n over 100.
the question is is this sufficient
in the correct language the key question
is this
can you use these local reductions to
reduce every line
in our small degree PC proof
in other words can we always express
every line in a for like the polynomial
p in a form like that where
each Pi is a local conclusion
and of course all their leading
monomials are no more than that our P
which is
if this is the case then I claim we're
done
right you look at an imagine proof line
by line then you will have that the
leading term of every line is locally
reducible
but the one polynomial is not locally
reducible because we have assumed that
every local study is satisfiable there
is no contradiction mechanical they can
imply
well the answer to the key question is
yes
uh well life is not that easy yes if you
don't encounter bad cancellations
what is about cancellation it's it's
such a lie where
both p and Q are as we want
some of local conclusions
however when you add them up after all
the crazy cancellations the new leading
term kept this m there becomes suddenly
irreducible to any local idea
actually it's not hard to see that to
prove degree lower bounds we only need
to make sure that this bad cancellation
cannot happen
it turns out to be equivalent to the
following condition on our collection of
local sets
it says let me read it for you for any
two local sets
in any low degree monomial amp if your m
is reducible but the idea generated by
the union of these two local sets your m
is already reducible by some local
setting or collection
for people who know from their basis
Theory this is actually an application
of this book broker's criteria
which demonstrates a quite remarkable
phenomenon on that if you have a magical
cancellation between 100 locals then
already you must be able to find no less
metrical cancellation between two locals
for us we just get a sufficient
condition for proving lower events
namely we just need a collection of
local sets that covers all axioms
each one is satisfiable
and this together satisfy that condition
a collection on such local sets oh sorry
and set as in such a collection is
usually called a closer set in the
literature
in one or another form
one last remarkable for before I turn to
the coloring problem
what's having such a collection of local
sets the analysis we made can usually be
put into the language of a student
projection I usually described as
piecing together this local reductions
but let me stop here regarding the
general framework
well finally we want to construct the
local sets for coloring problem
first let's adapt ourselves to the graph
theoretic language
recall that we when defining the
reduction you need a monomial order and
here we assume such a motor is induced
by the total order on vertices
and next for all how to pick a small
excellent subset we assume would pick a
small vertex at first and pick all the
activities about the coloring problem on
that induced graph
so the question is this what is a closed
set s for The Coloring problem
you're asking the case in all literature
we actually shoot for something stronger
we require that for all monomial amp
who's underlying vertices are in s s is
the best for reducing it
this means even if you take a slightly
larger set t t won't help you reduce
them furthermore
just a reminder in this language if you
think of it in terms of graphs m is
reducible by is it means it is a leading
monomial of some polynomial which
vanishes on all true coloring
assignments on this local set as
the key inside is this there is a pure
graph theoretic Criterion of this vertex
at s to guarantee the above competition
like in this picture which I'll explain
now
and here we do know the neighborhood
asks in T minus s to be V1 v through V2
and the conditions of the following
first of all
things are locally tree-like
namely these neighbors themselves should
be an independent set
and both each of them has a unique
neighboring s
finally
under the prefix vertex ordering hvi
is greater than its neighboring s
that's it
so this can be represented by us as here
you can direct the edges according to
the vertex ordering then all edges of
course all the corresponding edges
should be from the L sector s
in other words
the condition the new condition is
stronger than the original Star
condition
the new connection tells us that
actually the starting initial cells
there exists something as K that could
reduce energy the result of natural
cancellation here we're saying that you
don't need to choose K you just pick K
to be I or J
the new thing is produced from inj
okay I think
so in other words just a reformulation
of that graphia criteria as is closed if
it is downward closed in the sense that
if there is a path from s to some other
vertex that vertex is also in yes
and there is no two or three hops from s
to some to some some something else and
then back to us for example
too hot here is U to V1 to W which
doesn't exist here the three Hub is uv1
V2 W which also exists doesn't exist
here because this hash is nonsense or
uv1 b3w so on
for such an S we can prove
uh that is satisfying the property we
want the stronger property
before moving on let me just quickly
remark that this construction is for
four coloring problems
uh for free coloring you need to exclude
more small shapes like
made it through slightly larger hops or
degenerate hops which I won't Define
here
well the
Construction in fact gives us more
and not only it gives you a close assess
but actually starting with any given set
s you can find the smallest closed set
that contains it which we call the
closure of this sentence how
start with us take us down our closure
if you see small hops with respect to it
include the Hop
the curse until there is no hope
uh
it can be proved that this closure is
well defined and it satisfies the
natural monotonicity conditions and so
on
and this gives us a collection of close
sets that we want
how far are we now from
oh let me explain the collection of
local sets is the closure
counted overall small sets
collected overall smart sets
now how far away from a little degree
dealer actually degree Alpha and lower
bound I say one step
because we call two out of the three
conditions are already satisfied
covers all the axioms in satisfied store
the only thing left is to show that the
closure of a small cell is not too big
so that itself is satisfied if you
disclosure of something becomes the
whole graph the game is over
so the final step is to prove that
we use one last definition from this
Earth paper special vertex ordering
it's very simple actually
given a graph G you can color it by
kaijin and Colors by definition
then we choose our total vertex ordering
in any way that respects the color
classes
here's the picture
for example you let any vertex in V1 to
be larger than any other vertex in other
groups and so on
but the property we need about this
total order is only about any direct
path is now short founded by kaiji
of a random graph that is well known
that kaiji is something like d over log
d
in this case of large birds it is more
direct to see that the closure is small
but in our case we prove the following
number
which says if D is degree bounded and it
sparse on all small vertex subsets
then by then by sparse I mean
there are not too many edges on any
induced subset of response verdict set
which is known to hold for random graphs
and as mentioned uh the closure of small
service
so this llama achieves the last
condition of degree lower bound
Criterion we have then give you the
linear degree lower back
of course again uh what's stated here is
for the deregler graph model
a random graph there is no such
competition there because they might
have many not too many
large degree vertices and
overcome that we need some other
pseudonym properties about the graph
the proofs I'm sorry I will surely skip
them
many of the online audience can
entertain themselves with the slides
later if they wish
yeah
so in conclusion we proved a linear
degree hence exponential size lower
Bound for The Coloring problem for the
polynomial calculus and it's three
margin
open problems
the first is whether this closure
construction on graphs can find other
applications
by which I mean the total ordering of
vertices so that there is no long
directive path and the exclusion of
small shapes maybe they can be used more
in more general settings
second is coloring problem in other
proof systems
here let me erase some of squares in the
relatives for the atoms which I don't
need to Define out
is D to the one-half plus Epsilon
coloring hard for those Pro for those
Ortho rainbow graphs let's say
we know that
when a graph is tensor this is the case
it is hard
how about the sparse setting when D is
far smaller like super constant or
logarithmic
and adjust relative remark as Albert
mentioned in his talk
there is a degree two sum of squares
reputation of square root D coloring
morally speaking
then together with our results
we've seen an exponential separation
between
finally uh numerically speaking the
dependence on D in The Hidden constant
of the linear degree lower bound is in
fact at least exponential
but it seems a bit hard to say what kind
of dependence we should expect given
oops
given the many efficient sdp algorithms
that solve let's say
well nevertheless it's always good if
better dependence can be obtained that's
it thank you
[Applause]
any questions
is it for any of the finite Fields
sorry questions
yes it's pure independent
questions
the reduction did you ever make clear
what the explicitly the production
operator was is it just going to project
to the union of those closed sets or
something uh projection oh good question
I mean for this particular problem yeah
actually you can read it from here for
every small small monomial M you choose
a closed set that contains the
underlying vertices and do the true
reduction on the closed set that's it
I think it's quite great already so next
thing show and all the speakers in this
issue